SO LONG AS GOOD PEOPLE STAND UP.
NOT A LOT OF SCHOOLS OR STREETS
NAMED FOR JOE McCARTHY."
THE WORLD WAITS TO SEE THE
SURVEILLANCE MEMO,
PRESIDENT TRUMP BROUGHT HIS 2018
AFTER YESTERDAY'S TRAIN
ACCIDENT.
HE DID IT WITHOUT COMMENTING ON
ROBERTS TELLS US WHAT HAPPENED
TODAY.
>> YOU WILL AT THE STATE OF THE
UNION ADDRESS ON TUESDAY
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS CAUGHT ON AN
OPEN MIC TELLING A REPUBLICAN
PRESIDENT HAS READ THE CONTENTS
PRESIDENT HIMSELF IS PLAYING HIS
CARDS CLOSE TO HIS VEST.
>> ARRIVING BACK FROM
WEST VIRGINIA, PRESIDENT TRUMP
IGNORED QUESTIONS ABOUT THE FISA
ON HIS 2018 AGENDA.
>> WE'LL BE DEMONSTRATING THAT
SECURITY, IMMIGRATION REFORM.
PRESIDENT TRUMP BLASTING
DEMOCRATS FOR "DOING NOTHING
ABOUT DACA," REVEALING HIS OFFER
OF A PATH TO CITIZENSHIP FOR
>> I WANTED TO SEE WHETHER NOT
THEY WOULD APPROVE IT.
IF THEY DON'T APPROVE SOMETHING
WITHIN THAT SPHERE, THAT MEANS
SIMPLY THAT THEY ARE NOT LOOKING
TO PROVE IT AT ALL.
SPEAK UP AND IT WAS,
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID BY THE WAY,
DON'T CALL THEM DREAMERS.
>> SOME PEOPLE CALL THE
DREAMERS.
IT'S NOT DREAMERS.
DON'T FALL INTO THAT TRAP.
WE HAVE DREAMERS IN THIS COUNTRY
TOO.
>> DEMOCRATS HAVE NOTHING KIND
TO SAY ABOUT THE PRESIDENT'S
AGENDA.
NANCY PELOSI CALLING THE STATE
OF THE UNION ADDRESS A
"PERFORMANCE DEVOID OF ANY
SERIOUS POLICY IDEAS."
PRESIDENT TRUMP FIRED BACK,
HERE'S A SERIOUS IDEA.
HOW ABOUT BONUSES FOR WORKERS
FROM THE TAX CUT?
>> THESE CORPORATIONS GIVING
TREMENDOUS BONUSES TO EVERYBODY.
NANCY PELOSI CALLED THEM CRUMBS.
THAT WAS A BAD -- THAT COULD BE
LIKE DEPLORABLE.
DOES THAT MAKE SENSE?
DEPLORABLE END CRUMBS.
>> THE MINORITY LEADER'S OFFICE
REPLIED WHAT IS DEPLORABLE IS
BEHIND ONE-TIME BONUSES.
THAT WASN'T THE ONLY DUSTUP.
EARLIER AT THE REPUBLICAN
RETREAT, VICE PRESIDENT
MIKE PENCE TOOK A SHOVEL TO JOE
MANCHIN.
VOTED NO FOR TAX CREATORS, GOING
TO KEEP VOTING AGAINST
WEST VIRGINIA.
>> JOE MANCHIN DIDN'T LIKE IT,
TWEETING "MIKE PENCE TALKS A
GOOD GAME BUT I MET WITH 1321
TIMES TO MAKE TAX CUTS LARGER
AND PERMANENT FOR THE MIDDLE
CLASS.
NOT BIG BUSINESSES AND
MILLIONAIRES."
FOR HIS PART, THE PRESIDENT
SINGLED OUT DEMOCRATS WHO SAT ON
THEIR HANDS AT THE STATE UNION,
REFUSING TO APPLAUD.
>> WHEN I MADE THE STATEMENT THE
OTHER NIGHT, THERE WAS ZERO
MOVEMENT FROM THE DEMOCRATS.
WHICH TELLS YOU PERHAPS THEY
WOULD RATHER SEE HAS NOT DO WELL
THERE MAY NOT BE ANYTHING IN
PLACE OF THE TIME THE GOVERNMENT
IMMIGRATION PROPOSAL MAY NOT BE
AVAILABLE UNTIL AT LEAST
FEBRUARY 9, WHICH MEANS
NEGOTIATORS ARE GOING TO START
SOMETHING TO FIX DACA.
ON MONDAY.
IS THERE A SENSE THAT IT'S IT'S
GOING TO BE EASY TO GET A
CONTINUING RESOLUTION BY
FEBRUARY 8?
>> I'M TOLD THERE WON'T BE ANY
PROBLEM GETTING THE CONTINUING
RESOLUTIONS.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE NO APPETITE
TO SHUT THE GOVERNMENT DOWN
AGAIN.
WHAT WILL BE DIFFICULT IS
GETTING IT DEAL IN THE BUDGET
GAPS.
I'M BEING TOLD BY SOURCES AT THE
WHITE HOUSE WITH THE DEMOCRATS
ARE HOLDING FAST, THAT THERE
NEEDS TO BE IN AGREEMENT ON DACA
FOR THEY WILL TACKLE THE BUDGET